we know
america is not proud of their president
today they don't wake up in the morning
having the poster of their i would have
to say
in the last hundred years
if we had to say which president has the
least amount of posters in offices is
probably joe biden
i don't know if that makes sense or not
like you know how people proudly i saw
people proudly put up
by what do you call it obama on the wall
proudly oh people beyonce changed beyond
people
but people proudly put up trump not a
question but i would say people proudly
put up bush and bush and clinton okay i
i would go into offices to a lesser
extent of trump
no question but even if you go yeah you
know people proudly put up reagan for
sure people can't put up jfk no doubt
i'm telling you the poster business for
joe biden is struggling they're probably
fine you know who disagrees with you who
nobody yeah so nobody's like oh bite and
he's the man i love that guy yeah no
he's the anti-trump that's why he got
elected right he is the he's the he's
not the best anti-trump but he is the
anti-trump right he's the anti-trump